meta builds and releases a 175 billion
parameter language model a contrastive
captioning model out competes clip and
the open source dolly mega looks better
and better every day it trains welcome
to ml news
[Music]
this video is sponsored by weights and
biases if you don't know weights and
biases you're clearly missing out
they're the number one tool for ml ops
whatever you do they track your
experiments they optimize your hyper
parameters they make everything
observable they track your artifacts
your models your data sets your inputs
and your outputs of all the things that
you do they're with you from conception
of your idea to experimentation to
deployment and beyond it's really cool
they enable students they enable
professionals they enable researchers
personal accounts are free forever as
are educational accounts but the extra
benefits of weights and biases for teams
cannot be overstated everything you do
as a team is shareable you can write up
reports that you can share with your
teammates they can comment on it and all
of that is really cool they're in the
cloud but they do have options to host
on premise if that is important to you
and they're just all in all a great tool
they work seamlessly with a single line
of code that you add to your script and
from that they just track everything
they have integrations with all of the
popular frameworks so there's no reason
really to not try weights and biases use
my link that's 1db dot me
yannick to get a little surprise intro
and also to let them know that i sent
you thank you again so much to weights
and biases this is really awesome allows
me to do these videos and yeah let's get
into it
[Music]
and welcome to ml news my name is yanik
welcome to the channel we discuss the
newest happenings in the machine
learning world in fact so much time has
passed since the last news that i'm
having to split this episode into two
parts so you're seeing part one right
now and part two is going to be released
in a few days so keep an eye out for
that facebook releases a giant language
model the same size as gpt-3 but they're
just releasing it out into the wild not
entirely as we're going to discuss so
this is the first thing where openai
gets serious competition from open
source models so let's talk about it
meta-ai has a blog post called
democratizing access to large-scale
language models with opt-175b
now as i already said 175 billion
parameters is the exact size of openai's
gpt-3 remember that gpt3 is behind an
api so you don't necessarily get access
to it now openia has been building and
improving gpt3 over the time that it has
existed apparently or supposedly and the
model we're getting out here out of
facebook is just a straightforward
language model so without access to
gpt-3 we can't exactly tell where the
differences are however in the papers
the authors state that
opt-175b is comparable to gpt-3 while
requiring only one-seventh of the carbon
footprint to develop now besides the
blog post and the paper there is a
github repository to go along with that
which contains the code and also the
pre-trained models you can see they
release models starting from 125 million
parameters all the way up to 175 billion
now you can get up to the 30 billion
model just like that to download the
larger models you have to actually go
and ask them for it they will share it
with interested researchers but they
don't release it out into the world
quite yet so you're gonna have to wait
on that just a bit more what is also
interesting is that they published a log
book of training this model now the log
book is essentially where the
researchers keep track of what happened
during training of this giant language
model and so there's a goal there's a
purpose and there's some instructions
and after that you can find essentially
logs of what people did what they
experienced what they ran what problems
they encountered and so on so here you
can see all kinds of stuff like people
looking at the plots and finding out
interesting trends in the plots like
repeated patterns and some metrics you
can find logs of stuff crashing stuff
trying to auto recover and so on in fact
many times these people had to rewind
had to restart had to get their system
out from some kind of failed state and
so on it really gives you a nice insight
into the behind the scenes of training
these large language models because all
we end up seeing is usually just the
shiny paper at the front and the nice
results but reading this gives you a
much better impression of just how much
work goes into this so big props to meta
not only for releasing the models but
also showing a little bit behind the
curtain of what's going on though the
best take on this goes to you of
goldberg saying meta released opt-175b
but have you heard anything of opt-175a
what are they hiding couldn't have said
it better
there's a new paper called coca
contrastive captioners are image text
foundation models by google research
this is a model that ultimately competes
with clip among other things so the
model is trained on the configuration on
the left side right here there is an
image encoder there is a unimodal text
encoder which means it only takes text
there is a contrastive loss between
these two encoders and then there is a
multimodal text decoder which means that
it is essentially a language model that
also gets the image tokens as an input
so there are two losses involved right
here one is the contrastive loss between
the encoders and the other one is the
captioning loss from the language model
there are a number of special things the
first one is that the unimodal text
decoder is also an auto-aggressive
language model which is pretty
interesting in itself because usually
people use bi-directional models if they
just want to encode stuff but also the
system can be trained once and then used
in different configurations for either
fine tuning or even zero shot inference
for example the image encoder will have
very good representations for
fine-tuning a classifier on top of it
and the unimodal encoders both image and
text can be used directly as a
replacement for clip in order to assess
the alignment between text and images
given their contrastive loss training of
course given that the model is trained
essentially as an auto encoder for the
text with the help of the image the
model can also be used to do image
captioning and other things to do with
connecting text and images where the
output is text here's a bit of a deeper
insight into the model you can see that
the image is tokenized in classic vit
style whereas the text is first run
through an autoregressive decoder style
model even though it is technically
encoding the text what's special is that
we put a cls token at the end usually
it's put at the beginning it doesn't
really matter in bi-directional models
but in uni-directional models in
auto-aggressive models we have to put it
at the end to get the actual
representation out the representation of
that cls token and a pooled
representation of the image tokens will
be used for the contrastive loss whereas
the rest meaning the image tokens
themselves and the text tokens will be
used for the multimodal text decoder in
this plot right here in purple you can
see the new model it's called coca by
the way and how it stacks up against
other models that are either not
specialized just connecting text and
images somehow or even specialized model
for something so the difference here are
pretty significant sometimes for example
this is the table on zero shot image
classification on imagenet now zero shot
can be achieved by these image text
models because what you can do is you
can input the image and then ask the
model to simply get you the distance to
all of the class labels as text it's
actually a pretty neat way to do
classification and you can classify into
an open set and coca beats the other
models by a pretty good amount
especially compared to clip in the first
row and you see just how much progress
is being made in this field so again you
see there is another competitor to one
of openai's flagship models clip so
alone today we've seen a competitor to
gpt3 we've seen a competitor to clip and
what's the last one of openai's flagship
models well it's dali and as it turns
out boris daima is leading an effort to
reproduce dali out in the open now the
first model dali mini has already been
made and in fact you can try it out it's
pretty good so this is the eiffel tower
on the moon however dolly mini as the
name says is kind of a smallish version
of dali the new effort is dali mega
which is a proper large model and the
replication that resembles dully in
scale and performance here you can see
intermediate results this model is
training as we speak so on may 2nd it
was 29
done and you can see that it's already
producing pretty stunning images with
respect to the prompts that are given on
may 4th it was at 45 and this prompt
right here by rohan anil was apparently
pretty difficult for the model up until
this point it is spider-man on a horse
and yeah it doesn't look too
well yet and one person has actually
responded by inputting that prompt into
dolly too and giving us the picture out
of that or at least that's what is
claimed and these look pretty sweet i
have to say so i'm not sure if dolly
mega is going to match dolly 2 in its
performance it's certainly going to be a
good model but i do feel that delhi too
with its new architecture relying on
multiple internal models combining clip
with diffusion models and so on and what
i also suspect is that dully 2 had very
high quality data at least in part so i
guess it's going to be difficult to
reach that level of performance but
still an open source model that has such
a good performance is quite cool so this
project runs out in the open you can
actually look at the report and the
ongoing experiments on weights and
biases i'll link to it in the
description check it out
tortoise tts is a multi-voice text to
speech system that is trained with an
emphasis on quality an emphasis on
quality means it's very slow just so
we're clear but it is pretty cool
version 2.1 has just been released and
now you have the ability to use your own
pre-trained models and i have to say
this model is extremely good like it's
very good now there is a page with
hand-picked results and there is a
collab where you can experiment with the
model yourself but the author james
betker has made a custom model for me
and and sent me a little sample out of
that model and you just have to listen
to this i have never spoken this text in
fact this is a message that i sent to
him on discord and now it's just
available in my voice that would be fun
is this the model that is called
tortoise because it's very slow insane
it's me it's crazy i mean imagine just
the possibilities that open up with the
ability to just clone voices and let
anyone say pretty much anything you want
i mean obviously there's going to be
dangers ahead i mean essentially you
can't trust audio recordings anymore
where a person says anything but there's
also really cool things ahead and in
fact the project does include a detector
a model that recognizes whether or not a
given sample was created by the tortoise
system now knowing a bit about
adversarial examples it's fairly easy to
still use the system take the output and
then modify the output such that this
detector will not be tripped but at
least it is a first line of defense
against people who simply mindlessly
produce stuff and then put it out into
the wild but let me know what you think
this is essentially a deep fake system
for voices i think it's very cool let me
know in the comments
this github repository is very cool
probing vits vision transformers it's by
arithra rory goshtipati and sayak paul
and investigates visual transformers and
various variants of that like the
original vit the deit and dino and
applies various techniques to
investigate these models they've also
written this up in an excellent article
on keros.io that really takes you
through the research how to interact
with their stuff and reproduce their
results so the questions that can be
answered like this are things like what
do vision transformers learn or where in
a picture do vision transformers pay
attention to when they make a given
classification all of these things can
be achieved via techniques such as
attention rollout visualizing the
attention in an image visualizing
positional encodings and much more so if
you're interested to learn more about
how to investigate vision transformers
check out the repository and this
article
hugging phase launches the deep
reinforcement learning class so this is
a class about deep reinforcement
learning it's fairly applied but there's
also theory and the cool thing is you
will actually be using modern code so
libraries such as stable baselines three
which is not only for people trying to
learn reinforcement learning but this is
a serious library that is used in
practice now in conjunction with the
hugging face hub you can just publish
the agents you train and many people
have already done so now the course has
just started so there's still ample time
to join if you want to do so obviously
you can still go and read older stuff
but the next class will appear on may
11th and it's going to be a surprise oh
wow a surprise
[Music]
all right a few helpful things for this
week squirrel is a library to load
transform share and generally interact
with data sets so this unifies a number
of ways on how to interact with data
sets such as how to load data sets
either from disk or from distributed
sources then import them transform them
in some way and then feed them into your
machine learning pipeline and as you can
see from their benchmarks on various
data sets such as c4 100 which is images
wiki text 103 which is text data set
they outperform other data ingestion
pipelines by quite a bit so check out
squirrel core on github pyscript is not
necessarily a machine learning thing but
it is python inside of html which is
pretty crazy and this isn't just some
gimmicky thing no you can seriously pack
your modules and then ship them inside
of the browser run python in the browser
there's even a two-way interaction
between javascript and python so this
makes for some exciting new applications
that are now possible if you're
interested check out pyscript.net
big vision is an open source version of
the code base of a line of work starting
with vision transformers over mlp mixer
all the way to locked image text tuning
so all of this code is by the same or
similar groups out of google and this
code base is the home for that line of
research so check it out if you are
interested it's always cool to be just a
bit closer to the source of research
than the finished polished repositories
we usually see out of papers do you like
sports do you want to make some money
and also get to publish a paper at a
workshop these competitions here might
be for you the fifth international acm
workshop on multimedia content analysis
in sports hosts these four challenges
there is ball 3d localization camera
calibration instant segmentation and
player
re-identification all of them have
associated data sets and you can get
started right away there's even some
starter code available on github for
each of the challenges for you to get
into it but the challenges are
structured in two phases in the first
phase the winners go on and get to
publish their papers in the workshop and
in the second phase there's actual money
involved so the best team is going to
win 500 bucks and the most innovative
solution also wins 500 bucks and these
two things can be the same team so
that's a cool incentive to propose some
innovative solution that is also very
good alexei korshuk releases hugging nft
this is a code base to train gans on
nfts now where have i seen this before
this was literally released like one
week after i got done filming for my gan
ft video now i went through the
painstaking process of actually getting
the data getting the code training all
of it myself looking at the hyper
parameters yada yada yada alexa releases
a code base that makes all of this much
much easier because it's specifically
designed to interact with nft
collections so if you want to reproduce
what took me multiple weeks to perform
in a few hours check out this repository
alright here's our last article for the
day john deere is slowly becoming one of
the world's most important ai companies
this is by the next web and is an
article about an interview with john
deere not the person john deere a person
from the company john deere about their
advances into ai and i have to say it's
pretty cool whereas we still lack full
self-driving in cars on the roads for
tractors this has long been a reality
not only can these tractors drive
themselves the farmer can just control
them via an app is really crazy now
obviously this is promotional material
right here but i'm not really doubting
that they are already doing this what's
crazy here is that the tractors are not
only used for things like tilling but
they can also remove weeds with very
high precision as they do the tilling so
pretty crazy what's possible and we've
gone from a world where almost everyone
was a farmer to where almost no one is a
farmer and pretty soon actually no one's
gonna be a farmer now i'm not sure we
should probably not lose the last you
know one or two percent of humanity that
can actually produce food but i have to
admit it does look pretty sweet to have
a driverless tractor now wherever there
is technology there are hackers so this
is tractorhacking.github.io
which is not a malicious hacking but
apparently they say john here has overly
strict security on the electrical
component of its tractor sure overly
strict security on the electrical
components of your tractor that's
certainly a bad thing oh no security but
they do have a point obviously these
vendors lock down all the electronics so
that only they and their technician can
update them so this project is
investigating how to bypass those things
in order to repair those tractors
themselves so this already sounds a lot
more reasonable than just the name
tractor hacking but i still think it's
pretty cool so if you want to take part
there is a form right here i don't know
what happens if you fill out the form
but you know give it a shot and that was
already it for ml news thank you so much
for being here stay tuned for part two
which is going to come in a few days
time
see you around
[Music]